looking forward to the final of course
might be Germany I guess Brazil
[Music]
right now all the talk on the playground
is about the World Cup I feel happy and
excited about the World Cup coming to
Qatar and I get to watch my favorite
teams like Germany I see people around
me talking about football and I always
play football on lunch times my favorite
player is Karim Benzema I even named my
cat benzi after Benzema
for most of their lives it's right here
at my doorstep and I don't really need
to travel really far to go and watch the
matches and it's gonna be my first ever
World Cup I'm originally from Algeria
which makes me an Arab and I'm happy
that Qatar is the World Cup is being
held in Qatar which is an Arab country I
feel alive I feel so happy like I don't
know what to say
they also play at the LaSalle Academy
where they look to emulate their Heroes
my favorite player in the world cup is
sadio Mane and I'm really looking
forward to watching him since he is my
favorite ever footballer George work
image Chase
[Music]
the captain uh yeah and mooner Thomas
mooner
yeah why not
the coaches say the sport is helping to
build social skills and confidence
football is not just a training tool and
it's a tool for life
right now you see many kids playing
games here but our coaches are educating
key values that our players can learn
these values that they can take home
tonight
the dreams of seeing their heroes in
action is coming true and maybe one day
one of these children will become a
World Cup champion